ce sont deux légendes du tennis qui en
quelques heures seulement sont devenus
de légende d'internet alors que tous les
matches de tennis sont annulés en raison
du coc vite 19 rafael nadal et rodger
federer se sont lancés dans un match
avec les mots qui a fait mouche en
direct sur leur compte instagram les
deux hommes ont échangé autour de leur
rivalité légendaire ont parlé de leur
enfance mais ont aussi évoqué sans
détour la situation actuelle s'ils ne
peuvent plus participer à des tournois
de tennis depuis le 9 mars dernier en
raison du coc vide 19
rafael nadal s'est étonné de cette
interdiction alors que d'autres le droit
de continuer de travailler
elle va cair can can la louisiane par
lequel un point dimanche
c'est vrai que je ne comprends pas très
bien pourquoi on peut pas jouer au
tennis quand beaucoup de gens vont
travailler avant de préciser surtout
dans notre sport où nous gardons de
grandes distances de sécurité s'il ne
semble pas comprendre la décision du
gouvernement d'interdire leur activité
il reconnaît tout de même que ce n'est
pas la priorité du moment
je comprends qu'on est dans une
situation très compliquée et le
gouvernement est débordé par une
situation sans précédent et je comprends
aussi que le fait que nous puissions
nous entraîner ou non et bien la
dernière chose à laquelle pensent mais
pour l'espagnol ce manque d'entraînement
risque de faire des dégâts alors
comprenez vous le coup de gueule de
rafael nadal contre le confinement
[Musique]
alors oui mais est-ce que tu comprends
le coup de gueule de rafah non mais il
conclut à l'achat heureusement avec un
peu d'humilité que le tennis et les
entraînements c'est la dernière des
préoccupations ma mère de la cale et
joué dans son jardin si jamais ils
veulent se défouler je pense qu'il ya
des gens qui aimeraient ne pas
travailler mais qu'ils le font parce que
financièrement il son bord du gouffre
des caissières poser la question aux
caissières si elle pouvait s'arrêter
elle s'arrêterait des caissières sont
morts posez la question aux soignants
s'il pouvait s'arrêter pour se protéger
ils s'arrêteraient mais on n'a besoin de
personne est essentielle pour le bon
fonctionnement de la nation les éboueurs
les transporteurs les livreurs
voilà rafael nadal et ses interrogations
et ses craintes
franchement je m'en tamponne je m'en
fiche complètement
surtout que lorsqu'il parle du tennis
parle de tournois à son là on parle de
flux malgré tout il va prendre des tri
nations
alors vous avez vu qui importe c'est
bien patrick mouratoglou qui va lancer
un tournoi à huile ou j'en parlerai
demain parce que patrick c'est un pote
et c'est vrai ça chez moi la cc c'est
mon entraîneur je suis son plus mauvais
élèves gilles verdez
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord avec
jimmy parce que qu'on apprécie ou pas
nadal moi je les aime beaucoup mais il
ya un coup d'oeil sens et quand même il
dit est ce que je peux exercer ma
passion sa passion c'est de donner du
bonheur aux gens aussi mais lui vrai
mais oui mais en ce moment en ce moment
gilles on peut pas mettre des gens à
aller voir un match de tennis toute
façon ça ne serait que c'est un
épiphénomène raffarin c'est vraiment
voilà on va pas faire un ride et non oui
mais comme comme relancer le débat
moi je dis il me suggère frac et du
public
est ce qu'on ne peut pas jouer au tennis
à 8 longs relais une vraie question
qu'il suggère parce qu'il faudrait pas
se battre federer c'est ce qu'ils vont
lancer en tout cas voilà mathieu de
l'envoi c'est ce que va lancer patrick
moratoglou mathieu sur ce ton que les
silos bien intéressante qu'elle lui
rappelle nadal parce que honnêtement
aujourd'hui oui
bien malin celui qui peut vous dire
qu'il peut travailler ou pas je vous
donne un exemple tout bête mais vraiment
tout mais j'ai une une vieille 10 pm et
vomissent l'instant euros on s'en fout
ses moteurs de collection m'appelle
cette semaine le gage pour me dire on
peut faire ça ça ça dessus mais je dis
vous travaillez pas absolument donc les
mecs chez bmc en train de réparer ma
voiture j'aimerais juste comprendre là
c'est pas des caissières c'est pas alors
il s'est tout juste alors à l'olympia
maturi à la tu as travaillé qui n'a pas
le droit de travailler
alors juste g2 je retiens deux choses là
dessus 1 c'est vrai que c'est
complètement fou parce que le gars a
cloché même pas que les garages et
d'ouvrir et 2 mathieu bien entendu quand
il parlait de bien sûr réinsertion dans
la police il parlait bien sont donc
tendus de la police allemande puisqu'il
est tombé m
il va seconder le professeur eric 1 sur
la bundes traces amène entendu voilà ça
va être entre les mazures inspecteurs
wolfgang delorme olaria alors je fais ce
qu'on me dit tu as raison c'est vrai
jimmy c'est quoi c'est vrai quoi on voit
et moi je vais vous dire j'ai vu un
autre truc aussi c'est que j'ai vu de
plus en plus de restaurants qui rouvrait
pour faire du délit verrous voilà du web
une tout ça ouais et alors alors au
jimmy'z qu'étudier à sa baisse est liée
au fait que vous avoir des gens qui vont
être collés les uns aux autres on peut
aussi avec poser la question des
libraires les libraires ont été les
premiers à turcs eux on va fermer il ait
souffre et à ce moment là ils demandent
la réouverture mais les restaurateurs
c'est évidemment qu'il ya du contact
avec les gens vous et dans un endroit
fermé les les concessionnaires je suis
désolé mais les garagistes
oui il faut qu'ils restent ouverts vous
google etc travailler votre voiture
tombe en panne préparez donc il ya un
minimum de services qui sont nécessaires
à la nation le tennis je ne suis pas sûr
que ça fasse partie pourquoi pas le golf
dans ces cas là pourquoi pas finalement
le baby foot
le baby-foot les pelouses dans deux
minutes à redon et les pardons ça veut
dire que oui si bien compris puisque
visiblement c'est un peu selon selon moi
demain si je veux retourner dans ma
boîte de prod de travail et j'ai droit
vous n'avez une boîte de prod vous êtes
inspecteur de police
mais non mais c'est tellement fou c'est
aberrant c'est jimmy james joue déjà ses
preuves sous pardon parce qu'il ya une
augmentation avec des textes précis où
toutes les professions sont précisément
site étant qu'il permet au groupe à
concernant les restaurants ce qui
réouvre ils font pas venir du public à
l'intérieur dans mon lit d'hôpital et
les gens rentrent qu'un parent et on
leur fait passer en fait ce qui est
préparé et ça c'est depuis le début du
continent
heureusement est ce que vraiment ça mais
justement laurent offert